من جنديرس فيري في حلب عاطف نعنون مدير
فريق ملهم التطوعيه معنا الان
اخبرنا عن هذه الحالات
سيد
عاطف
يعني ماذا تفعلون في ظل نقص الامكانات
والمعدات حاليا في هذا الطقس السيء
والعاصف ايضا
مساء الخير لحضرتك الساده المشاهدين
والرحمه الى الشهداء الزلزال
والشفاء للجرحى
للامانه ما في كلمات توصف الواقع الاليم
اللي عم يمر فيه الشعب السوري يعني لما
نحكي عن زلزال
بوقت يعني صباح يوم الاثنين الساعه اربعه
ونص الفجر ما كان في حدا الا تحت سقف ما
كان في حدا بالطرقات اثناء عاصفه ثلجيه
بمنطقه منكوبه اصلا من عشر سنوات تعرضت
القصف وتكرارا
بسيطه القصه بسطرين نحن مين ممكن يتخيل شو
النتائج ممكن يتخيل شو اللي ممكن يصير
بالناس النازحه اللي تعبت من القصف والموت
بكل الاشكال انه يجيها زلزال على مقياس
يمكن سبعه ونص عن القياس
بمنطقه جندي على الارض للاسف في منطقه
حارم
وترمانين والارب وسلقين مباني كتير تدمرت
حتى المدينه مباني كثير تدمرت للاسف يعني
ما في كلمات توصف توصف الحاله القصص كثيره
يمكن نحن نشوف الفيديو اللي عرضتوني شوي
انه هاي حاله يتم انقاصها الحمد لله رب
العالمين لا اعتراض على حكم الله ولكن عدد
الضحايا كبيره جدا يعني
لما نحكي نحن عن اسر كامله دعوات كل عشرات
الافراد من اسرته حاليا انا فاتح محادثه
شخص عم يقول لي انه انه في طفل ما لقينا
حدا من عيلته فاعطيناه لاخو جدو فهي هاي
المسج هلا وصلتني من شوي
انا قاعد بخيمه لانه ما بقى في امان
بالسقف انا من الاشخاص اللي هدروا الزلزال
انا اسطنبول ولكن من شهرين مقيم في شمال
سوريا بسبب انه عم ننهي مجموعه من القرى
السكنيه اللي عبرناها كفريق
كرمالنا للناس من خيام لبيوت حاليا
من الخوف من الازل نفسي الاصابه ومن الرعب
انا هلا لهلا ما عم بسترجي اطلع انام
بالبيت
فالعالم عم تنصب خيام بتنتقل من البيوت
للخيم او للسيارات تتحدث عن عن طفل معك
وقطعته تفضل
صحيح طفل اسمه ابراهيم عمره سنه ونص من
ثلاثه ايام هو موجود
بالمشفى كان وحيد بدون ام واب طلعت اشاعات
او سالنا نحن المرض ممرضين لما كنا عم
نزور المرضى عفوا الجرحى ونسالهن عن
اوضاعهن ونعطيهم الاكل لانهن بدون اكل
بدون ثياب بدون شيء خلونا هذا بدون اب وام
فصورته انا فيديو انا وصديقي فيديو احنا
بنعطيه موزه فانتشر الفيديو يمكن يحقق
مئات ملايين المشاهدات على السوشيال ميديا
وكل العالم
ضلينا عم نحاول انه ندور على ابوه او امه
او حدا بركي بيطلع حدا من عيلته عايش قبل
ما ندخل بموضوع التبني ونشرها اليوم الصبح
فيديو انه هذا الطفل نحن ما بدنا ندخل
لموضوع التبني له اطلاقا لانه لعل وعسى
يكون حدا من اهله عايش اجا الخيمه هاي
والده وقف على باب الخيمه
ما بيقدر يمشي
لعند ابنه الابن عمره سنه ونص لما اجى
يحضن الاب الاب ما قدر يحضنه وصار الاب
بيبكي ان شاء الله هذا الفيديو من شوي على
صفحة عم بيقول انا ما عم بقدر اشيلك شاف
اطمن عليه واحنا على اساس نسلموا الولد
يعني بس ما كانت متوقعين الاب بهالحاله
اخدنا الاسعاف على المشفى المشفى قال انه
لازم ينام عنا الاب فساله الاب قلت له شو
الوضع يا عم انت ومين احكي لي شو قصتك انا
وقع فينا البيت انا وام الولد ما حدا يجي
غير انا وهالطفل لسه في طفل عمره خمس
سنوات تحت الانقاذ وطفلتي وزوجتي توفوا
ودفنون هاي الكارثه انه هو بيحكي لي هذا
الحكي وهو رايح على المشفى لما راح على
المشفى انه انت كيف كيف مانك بالمشفى هلا
الاب هلا حاليا بالمشفى وترك الطفل اماني
عنا هاي انا بحكي انا على حاله
من الاف الحالات القصص كثيره
بما انه هذه الحاله يعني صراحه ايضا انا
شخصيا شاهدتها وكما قلت انتشرت بشكل كبير
ظننا ان والد هذا الطفل الذي كان ياكل
الموزه
ووجهه
يعني مدمى
ابوه ما زال على قيد الحياه ابوه تعرف
عليه وجاء الى الخيمه لكي ياخذه امه توفيت
واخت واخته توفيت واخوه خمس سنوات تحت
الانقاض لحد اللحظه والاغلب يعني توفي
اكثر من 90 ساعه انا ممكن ممكن اذا فيني
اتحرك الكاميرا يعني اورجيكم الطفل نعم
نعم اكيد
هذا الطفل اسمه ابراهيم
عمره سنه ونص هلا نام
يعني يعني عم نحاول قد هذا الطفل الذي
الذي ظهر وهو ياكل الموزه فقط للتاكيد
صحيح هذا هو الطفل طبعا عنده صفائح برجله
يعني هلا الشباب شباب الفريق شباب الفريق
ملهم هلا من دقائق اشتروا له ثياب
واكل هلا الساعه من حوالي من حوالي من
حوالي ساعه بلش يبكي الطفل عم نحكي عن قصه
وحده لحتى نحن يعني
نموذج نموذج
من مئات او الاف القصص صار يبكي ساعه 12
تقريبا صار يبكي لما
بعتت لعمو للطفل انه شو السبب
قام قال لي انه لانه كان بيرضع بيرضع من
امه يعني انت بس تتخيل لحالك انه طفل كان
برضع من امه بينحط على صدر امه يعني وبنام
هلا هيك فجاه ما بقى في ام ابوه بالمشفى
ما بقى في اخ ما بقى في بيت ما بقى في شيء
عيش عم يطلع على وجوه ما بيعرفها
في في قهر طفل طفل لما انتشر الفيديو تبعه
السبب انتشار الفيديو تبعه هو القهر اللي
بعيونها الطفل عمره سنه ونص هو فهمان شو
عم بيصير يعني بتحس انه انه هو
كطفل خلاص بس لما شاف ابوه كنا نحنا عم
نقول انه احنا خايفين الاطفال لما يصير في
كوارث بصير في مشاكل بموضوع الاطفال
والتعرف عليهن والى ذلك
فكان عم بيقولوا انه لما نشوف طفل لازم
نحن نتاكد انه هذا ابوه ولا عمه ولا حدا
مشان ما يصير اي مشاكل من دون يعني من اول
لحظه ببين طفل شاف الف شخص يمكن بهالفتره
لما شاف ابوه والله العظيم
يعني
تتحركت عيونه الاب وقف مثل مثل كانه ما
قادر يعمل مرته عم بتذكر ابنه التانيه تحت
الانقاض بهالبرد عم بتذكر بنته اللي توفت
الاب قال انا تحت الانقاذ العشر ساعات عم
فكر بس
يعني شايف الفيديو ايضا
نشرنا اليوم فيديو كررنا فيه نداء انه
الطفل هذا موجود معنا
قربت على وشه بالفيديو قلت انه هذا الطفل
مواصفاته يعني وهي شكله رجاء من اي شخص
بيعرفوا انه يوصل لعنا فريق واسع على
السوشيال ميديا طبعا وصل الفيديو لانه
الاب ما عنده جوال الاب ما عنده شيء غير
بجامته اللي طلع فيهم تحت الانقاذ لعم
الطفل اجا العم الطفل واجا الاب الاب ما
كان لازم يجي يعني لانه ما كان في اصلا ما
بعرف كيف اجى يعني للامانه متل ما خبرتك
المشفى لازم تكون انت بالمشفى كيف انت برا
المشفى هو بس كان رايح على مسافر على
مدينه تانيه مشان يدور على ابنه تحت
الانقاذ
لحتى يشوفوا اللي هو معنا تمام فبالتالي
الاب مدمر نفسيا مدمر جسديا
هذه القصص لا تنتهي هذه القصص في الحقيقه
لا تنتهي وهذا مجرد نموذج توسعنا به فقط
للاضاءه على نموذج من الاف وعشرات الاف
النماذج لاطفال فقدوا ابائهم وامهاتهم
وعوائلهم ايضا
اشرت الى الخيمه الخيمه اكبر دليل عما
تحتاجونه انتم كفريق تطوعي مع هذا العمل
الذي تقومون به ما الذي تحتاجونه الان
بكل بكل ازمه او بكل حصار او قصف بصير
احنا بنطلب دائما دعم دعم مادي او او دعم
لوجستي او دعم مواد عينيه وما الى ذلك اول
اول شيء طلبته من الناس انا يوم اللي شفت
الكارثه يوم شفت جنديرس المدينه الاكثر
تضررا قلت ما بنطلب غير الدعاء نحن بشيء
ما حسيت انه ما له حل بالاول بعدين لما
صرنا نطلع من طور الصدمه بعد حوالي 24 او
48 ساعه حتى نطلع من طور الصدمه اللي كنا
فيها الا انه
لننقز من تبقى يعني اي روح تستاهل انه
نبذه مشان اجهزه بالفعل في ابطال الملائكه
من الدفاع المدني السوري عم يقوموا محل
دول محل محل هيئات كوارث كانهم خبراء
بيشتغلوا بالزلازل من مئات السنين ما شاء
الله عنهم ليل نهار 24 ساعه بيحاولوا
انقذوا الناس وتم انقاذ عدد كبير من الناس
شوي
المنظمات المج المدني والجمعيات والفرق
التطوعيه شغاله على مدار الساعه تحاول انه
تامل الاكل الناس اللي موجودين ولكن نحن
الان
ما بعد الصدمه
بالاحصائيات عم تبرز الناس اللي دفنه
ضحايا انه كان في انه كان في كان في
انتظار كان في انتظار للناس تخرج ضحايا
لتدفنون هلا عم بيدوروا على بيوت الاف
العائلات شكرا بالمساجد
بذور الايواء والوضع جدا كارثي ورب
العالمين يكون بعون العباده شكرا لك عطف
نعنوع من جنديرس في ريف حلب مدير فريق
ملهم التطوعي